I want to say something profound about
David Crosby It's the problem is I'm not
really profound you know but uh I did
love that guy I can't tell you
let's see if I can articulate why I
loved him so much David was just so
great and what a voice right he
co-founded the birds 1964 with Roger
McGuinn and Gene Clark their cover of
Bob Dylan's Mr Tambourine Man was
considered the birth of folk rocks and
they fired him guy rode Eight Miles High
you don't kick him out of the band kick
everyone else out of the [__] band so
he leaves and you know you know the
story takes up with two incredible
musicians Stephen Stills who's a [__]
genius from Buffalo Springfield and he
hooks up with Graham Nash from the
Hollies you know he told me how excited
he was when he joined uh you know Steven
Stills Stephen was unbelievable right
really underrated guitar player right
yeah guitar player writer he was already
writing great [__] but isn't it scary to
go off with Stills when you've already
got this great relationship with the
birds you guys are awesomely famous
making lots of money it is a risk right
it's like you don't think that way not
exactly no I mean yeah I like I like
having a job and I like making money
it's good it's a good tool right but
music really speaks to me and and
Steven's music really spoke to me it was
brand new fresh strong faulty good when
they put out that first album while it
wasn't the massive hit that Deja Vu was
they won a Grammy for that Best New
Artist but I loved Crosby Stills Nash
and Young so much the album Deja Vu was
one of my favorite albums growing up and
when I say favorite I'm putting it right
in the top five every [__] song is
great every song was a hit yeah I mean
what a talent what a guy here's Crosby
talking about social responsibility
music you know he really he he not only
loved making music but
um you know he was a he was a crusader
part of our job is left over from being
Troubadours from the Middle Ages you
know when we were the we were mass media
part of our job is to say Hey you know
12 o'clocks and all as well or or it's
11 30 and the government's been bought
and sold and things are going down the
tubes it's part of our job my thing in
high school in college was I got my news
from rock bands well when they were guys
with the prophets it was a righteous
deal because America starts killing its
own children you know something is
goddamn well wrong
and we knew it and we called it out and
we said Nixon you I made it my mission
to get Crosby Stills Nash and Young
together again but I couldn't oh no it
was a losing battle Neil Young put out a
really classy stand Neil said we had so
many great times especially in the early
years Crosby was a very supportive
friend in my early life as we bit off
big pieces of our experience together
David was the Catalyst of many things my
heart goes out to Jan and Django his
wife and son lots of love to you thanks
David for your spirit and songs love you
man I remember the best times and that's
classy that's like you know what yeah
okay
maybe some [__] went down but there were
a lot of good times and those guys loved
each other there's a couple of things I
really loved too it was a time where
they put out a documentary on David
Crosby I went to a screening and I sit
down in my seat who's sitting right in
front of me is David Crosby with his
wife Jan it was a great movie and it was
weird to be sitting right behind him
during it because it was a very raw kind
of documentary like there was nothing
held back but I remember sitting behind
him I go Jesus Christ there's my Boyhood
hero Crosby's Crosby of Crosby Stills
Nash and Young I never would imagine I'd
be sitting behind him in a movie theater
watching the story of his life with him
you know and I said hello and we gave
each other a hug and I said David happy
to be here to see your movie and I just
felt such compassion for him and love
for him I really did I just loved the
guy I remember his last appearance here
he put out a new album and I listened to
the album was fantastic it really was
his last afraid to put out new music no
right up until the end of his life and
here's uh David Crosby in his own words
about the end of life people get old and
die and that's how that's how it works
and I'm gonna uh but in the meantime I'm
gonna have myself a bunch of fun it's
not how much time you got because we
really don't know uh
I I could have two weeks I could have
ten years it's what you do with the time
that you do have
and so I'm trying to really spend it
well whatever each day that I get I'm
very grateful for and I try to
do it making music because I think the
world needs music I think music is a
lifting force and I think that I can
make good music because I love doing it
I know that I'm supposed to you know
quietly Shuffle off into the distance
but
I'm not gonna We Lost
such a great guy and such a great
performer and a very important guy in
the history of rock and roll geez I got
a kick out of knowing him it was really
special for me to note David Crosby